made by ph/ Rayan Mahmoud
faculty of pharmacy , alexandria university
a stroke occurs when the blood flow
in part of your brain is blocked
after just few minutes
the starved brain cells begin to die
normally the brain recieves blood
via two major pairs of arteries
which branch through out brain tissue
and supply your brain cells with
a constant flow of oxygen , glucose and nutrients
necessary for their functions
during a hemorrhagic stroke
abnormal bleeding disrupts normal blood flow
for example in an intracerebral hemorrhagic stroke
a blood vessel bursts spilling blood directly into your brain
will robbing an intended tissue of nourishement
both the hemorrhage and lack of blood supply
called ischemia destroy brain tissue
a subarachnoid hemorrhagic stroke
occurs when a weak spot in a blood vessel wall
called an aneurysm bursts
and leaks blood into the tight space between
your brain and your skull
the high pressure bleeding results in
a serious damage to brain tissue
immediate treatment for your stroke may help
to minimize brain cell injury and death
in a case of hemorrhagic stroke
emergency surgery may be necessary
to repair damaged arteries
or reduce the pressure of blood on your brain
you may be given medication to help
the brain's blood flow return to normal
made by ph/ Rayan Mahmoud
faculty of pharmacy , alexandria university